Where P is the principal amount borrowed,
A is the periodic amortization payment, r
is the periodic interest rate divided by 100…
Philip, I think it’s a little early for
this...
Oh yea, this is maybe more bedtime reading.
Not early in the day!
Early in her life.
I just want her to have a good headstart.
They say kids who learn about money early
on develop better financial habits as adults.
But she’s only three months old!
You mean one fiscal quarter old.
I’m putting her down for a nap.
A recent study found that 44% of Americans
consider personal finance to be the most difficult
topic to discuss with others, moreso than
politics, religion or death.
Maybe that’s why most parents are more comfortable
discussing “birds and bees” than “terms and fees.”
See what i did there?
And when parents do discuss finances with
their children, they tend to limit it to simple
ideas like saving, spending, and earning.
Researchers at North Carolina University found
that children sensed that certain topics were
“off-limits,” including family finances,
parental income, investments and debt.
If investments and debt were discussed at
all, they were far more likely to be discussed
with boys and not girls.
And most children had no idea why their parents
were secretive about these things.
The truth is that money management is one
of the most useful skills for getting by in
our modern world, and yet one that many Americans
are never formally taught--not in school or
from their parents.
So who does teach today’s children about
money?
Advertisers.
Who, believe it or not, might not have your
family’s best interests at heart.
Unfortunately, there are a lot of predatory
organizations out there that make big profits
from other people’s poor financial decisions.
Don’t get us wrong, making mistakes is an
invaluable part of the learning process.
But when you’re young, mistakes don’t
hurt that much.
If your lemonade stand doesn’t sell enough
units to cover overhead, well, you’re out
a couple bucks, but you’ve learned an important
lesson on managing cash flow.
That same lesson in your twenties will cost
you a heck of a lot more than a couple bucks.
In fact, it could set you on a slippery slope
to lifelong debt.
A study by by Edutopia found that kids who
were taught financial literacy tended to have
less debt and a higher net worth as adults.
Now we’re not suggesting you run off and
discuss correlation coefficients with your first grader!
As your child’s brain develops, certain
topics will be more age appropriate than others.
When a child is between 4 and 6 they’re
ready to be introduced to the basic concepts
of money: Money buys things, it can be earned,
and some people have more than others.
Games that use coins or paper currency can
be a great way to make money seem less abstract
and more concrete.
At around 6 to 9 years old, children can begin
interacting with money in the real world.
You might decide to give them a regular allowance,
or “pay” them for doing extra chores
or getting good grades.
This is also a good time to encourage giving.
Help them pick a charity that they like, and
take them to make a donation in person, to
see the human impact of their gift.
Between 10-15, kids become able to absorb
more advanced financial concepts, like borrowing
and investing.
If your child has their heart set on a big
purchase, you might consider loaning them the money.
You could even consider charging them interest
(and putting it in their college funds).
Better they learn the concept from you than
a credit card company.
Alternatively, if they’ve managed to save
some money, help them research investment
options like a CD, savings bond, or index
fund.
Nothing can get them excited about finances
like watching their money grow!
As they become a teenager, you should begin
to reveal greater details of your own financial
habits and situation.
I know, it seems… weird.
But frank discussions about your salary, mortgage,
taxes--even debt--could give them a huge leg
up as adults.
If there's something in your finances you're not so proud of well...
There’s nothing more natural than kids learning
from their parents’ mistakes.
It’s also the best way to familiarize them
with the logistics of money management: ATM’s,
digital banking, accounting apps.
Show them how you actually keep track of your
balances and pay your bills.
Most people have to figure that stuff out
all on their own, but it doesn’t have to be that way.
Remember, you don’t have to be a perfect
teacher.
Many parents don’t bring up the topic of
money because they don’t want to say the
wrong thing, but any kind of introduction
is better than none at all.
One way or another, your kids will learn these
lessons.
Wouldn’t you rather it come from someone
who genuinely wants what’s best for them?
And that’s our two cents!